sapeur pompier un métier qui fait
toujours rêver dans notre calendrier de
l'avent de tv78 je vous propose
aujourd'hui un ouvrage qui parle de la
profession au plus
[Musique]
petit à la caserne au cœur d'une
intervention le livre animé des pompiers
transportent les jeunes lecteurs dans le
quotidien des soldats du feu quel
matériel embarquent-il dans leur camion
comment se protègeent-t-il du feu
Sébastien Frémont sapeur pompier
professionnel des Yvelines et annne
Sophie Boman répondent à toutes ces
questions en images dans cet ouvrage
découvrirez 20 animations pour habiller
les pompiers déplacer des engins ou
encore déployer la grande échelle et
même un pop-up qui permet de voir une
scène de feu en trois dimensions on y
trouve aussi des petites fiches pour
sensibiliser les enfants aux accidents
de la voie publique et aux incendies
domestiques le livre animé des pompiers
est édité chez tourbillon et est
disponible au prix de 12,90
€